wow so you've had you actually are
inspired and triggered by things that
you see in life you chase it and then
these things actually happen because I
also know that and maybe you don't want
to talk about Paul Stanley is not your
real name but right Paul yes is because
of your inspiration yeah that's not true
that is Paul McCartney Right McCartney
Paul Rogers a great singer
um when I was a little kid
I said to my parents I hate my name
what's your first name it was Stanley so
I decided to keep Stanley as my last
name to retain some sort of connection
to my past
but my parents said to me well you can
change it when you get older I don't
think they really believed I was going
to change it but I did were they alive
when you changed it yes yes
um
were they happy with that or I think you
know
Jewish parents you know have a a certain
connection to their their past and um
look I was baffling to them anyway I was
running around in tights and high heels
you know with white makeup and putting a
guitar between my legs so to begin with
I was a bit strange but um I think I
think it was uh a little hard on them um
I think it was a little hard on my dad
what business was he in he was in office
furniture very super bright guy who
never really found a way to to manifest
his intelligence he was uh graduated
high school 16 and should have gone on
to college but his parents
um pardon me
I think they they kind of stronged on
strong-armed him into working to provide
for the family and
um I think he was frustrated through his
life because uh he was really a very
very Innovative very interesting guy
probably 50 years ago he came home one
night and brought home Evian bottles
that he had brought you know in some
import store and he said this is the
future of and I went nobody's going to
buy water you know he saw that yeah and
he did other things just like that and
you know I was like Dad you turn on the
faucet it's free you're not going to buy
bottled water so lo and behold so he was
uh but yeah I think it was a bit
difficult were they proud was that a it
was they had to be proud because uh
having uh being a an attender of uh of a
Kiss concert I can't imagine what that
would feel like if that's my son I mean
that that crowd and still to this day
that crowd is a rabid so I mean yeah we
just you know we were just playing two
weeks ago 80 000 people hundred thousand
people you know intimate 18 000 people
um I I again I think it it was a bit
difficult for my my dad to see my
success when success
um eluded him really you don't think as
a well then that that you're bringing up
something I'm not telling you to lie
down on the couch but I will tell you as
a father I'm sitting here with my
daughter I want more for my children
than I have and I agree with you nothing
you know pleases me more than seeing my
children
um exceed what I've done in certain
areas and uh yeah I think as parents
that's what we want
um look
people aren't perfect and my parents
certainly weren't perfect and and um I
think it it was tough for my dad because
it
instead of looking at my successes and
seeing that he was a part of it I think
my my dad saw it as uh a reflection of
his inadequacies wow boy we're getting
deep here oh no but I'm Into You Know
mental health is my whole uh platform
but I didn't think that we were gonna
get that what about your kids are they
anybody interested in music
um no
um I think well my oldest yeah he's he
went to NYU to Tish and graduated magna
[ __ ] laude so um in music yes I mean it's
amazing because again the only way I I
could ever have gotten into a college
was through the window you know so so
what does he want to do what does he do
he does music and he makes you know I
don't give him any money I I
up until the time he went to school he
was uh delivering for a deli so you know
I I want my kids to not have that sense
of entitlement what is it what kind of
music is he doing
um very modern well you know very
contemporary although he started off as
an amazing blues guitar player he's a
really good guitar he's a wonderful and
he's he's a spectacular guy you know
what's his name his name's Evan okay and
is that his stage name too Evan Stanley
yeah that's uh okay so I'm telling
listeners going they can download can
you stream his stuff yes and he's also
uh he's out uh doing shows now so he
he's playing in Los Angeles and uh you
know it's it's
I'd like to see that work ethic
manifested in all my kids you know if
anything I want to lead by example you
know your kids
aren't really taken with what you tell
them but they're more taken with what
they see so I think my my kids have seen
that I've worked hard I wrote a book
more for them than for me so that you
know I I was in a position where
my kids could could know my story
and um you know know that it didn't
nothing was handed to me I worked hard
and uh I think it's reflected in them my
my um my 16 years he'll be 16 next month
Colin is in Florida right now in a
basketball camp
um he works out twice a day on his own
has nothing to do with being pushed he
shoots baskets all day he's also a
great student and uh does he is does he
aspire to be professional in basketball
yeah and I yeah I'm not one of those
people who believes that well you know
anything is possible if you work hard
what's possible is what's possible for
you if you work hard you can achieve it
so
um for me it's always been do a hard
assessment of yourself of what you're
good at and what you are capable of and
then the hard work can pay off if I had
decided to become a mathematician I'd be
homeless I had I had no ability in math
so wait you know that's funny that you
should say that because there is a court
and you would know that my daughter's a
teacher there I've heard that there is a
correlation between math and music
have you have you not heard that well I
am I am the exception to that rule
but there is something to have you not
heard that am I alone on this no am I
alone on this no I I've heard the same
if they're talking about addition and
subtraction then yes but if you get past
there and and I'm in trouble so you've
said you don't give your kids money
they're financially independent but do
you ever open doors for them make
connections for them
um I I've done that but I I don't have
an issue with that because
to me
I can open a door perhaps
but
that dog can get slammed also I can open
that door but then you're on your own
um so have I have I said you know would
you um
check out my son or whatever yeah but um
they can slam the door
thank you
[Music]
foreign